THE HELMET AND GET GOING.
THE DISCOVER MATCHUP  ON
TONIGHT'S NETMINDER'S.
>> Craig: RANTA THE
LEAFS ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY.
FREEZING THE
THE BAR.
NO CHANCE FOR SAMSONOV.
A TURNOVER TO THE LEFT OF HIM
IN THE CORNER.
HERE GOES FOR HER .
>> Craig: FROM ABOUT MID
DECEMBER TO NOW,FINE AS
FEHERVARY SINCE IT IN.
REILLY AVERAGES BETTER THAN 24
MINUTES PER GAME.
>> Craig: HE'S THERE JOHN
CARLSON.
>> Joe: CORNERMRAZEK IS RIGHT ER
TO MATTHEWS AND GIVES HIM THE
KNEE TAP THERE, KEEPING THAT
PUCK OUT THE PUCK IS GOING
WIDE AND WHAT A DEFLECTION THAT
IS FD  OF BUNTING.
HE KNEW HIM FROM THE OH IN
SAULT STE.
MARIE TO THE TOP
SHELF.
KNEE LANDER ON THE BOARDS.
>> Craig: THEIRS THAT DASHER
WORK BY ELLER WHO COULDN'T
CONTROL.
THAT LEADS THE PLAY TO LEND
SUPPOR
BATTLES, AND THE CAUSE OF TH
AND THEN WITH BROPHY.
>> Joe: 90 SECONDS TO OPERATE
WASHINGTON WHEN I WAS HERE.
SHE GREW UP SEEING PICTURES OF
ME WITH NUMBER 8 SO WHEN SIT
AND RIP IT.
THERE IS ANOTHER WEEK
OFF, BASICALLY.
LILJEGREN SENDS IT DOWN.
BA
CALL AROUND THE BLOCKER AND
SNEAK IT PAST THE GOALIE.
THE CAPITALS HAVE CLAWED THEIR
WAY BACK.
ERRANT  PUCK ALONG THE WALL.BACE
FRONT, BEAUTIFUL GOAL  MAKES IT
WHAT A PLAY , AND HE
RIPS IT.
GETS A LITTLE LUCK THERE AND
GOES QUICKLY PAD
OUTWEIGH ABOVE, SORT OF AN
AWKWARD LOOKING PLAY.
VERY GOODBYE MRAZEK.
>> Joe: OVECHKIN MAKES THEFIVE,
THE GOALIE PULLED, AND GET
STRIPPED, AND ENGV